there's also like full-on burnout where
you don't function anymore i had that
where you're basically clinically
depressed but there's another form of
sean that i call low-grade burnout and
that i define it as this the joy of life
is gone but the functions of life
continue so you're going to work you're
showing up but like you used to love
youtube now you're just like oh another
day another video another day another
tick tock another day another whatever
and your heart is dead
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres the host of this
show and on this podcast we help you
grow your youtube influence and then
turn that youtube influence into a high
impact and a high income online business
we're teaching all the tips and tools of
how to make this possible and i want to
welcome all of the new listeners to the
podcast thank you for being here today
this is going to be a power packed
episode for you and i cannot wait to get
into it and i want to encourage you to
subscribe wherever you're consuming this
content we are putting this podcast out
to all of the major podcasting platforms
as well as youtube so if you've not been
over to our think media podcast channel
make sure to head over there and
subscribe
because we have other episodes that drop
exclusively on the youtube channel now
we are in a two-part series with one of
our mentors and really the kickoff for
the theme of our year here at think
media we have none other than carrie
newhoth on our podcast now if you've
been with us for any length of time you
know that this year we have marked it
with at your best and sean actually went
through
two different sessions already we have
other sessions coming in the future this
year for you of how we are helping our
team be at their best and so we wanted
to bring none other than the author of
this book
to the podcast to interview him on going
deeper into his body of work and just
some advice for you as a content creator
now today's episode is all about burnout
and carrie is no stranger to burnout he
actually wrote a whole book on that and
we wanted to talk about it because it is
something that is very prevalent in the
creator community and so today we're
going to be talking about how you can
actually go from the stress spiral into
the thrive cycle and his tips for
content creators who are starting to
feel like they're on the edge of burnout
all of that and more in today's episode
so let's jump into today's featured
content
[Music]
are you feeling burnt out
how do you beat stress and ultimately
create your best content on youtube and
on social media well in this
conversation i'm so excited because
we're really going to be talking about
how to
overcome burnout get into your
green zone get out of the stress cycle
and into your thrive cycle
and ultimately talking with carrie new
off now if you haven't met kerry before
he's an incredible individual he's a
best-selling author speaker former
attorney and he's one of today's most
influential video podcasters his youtube
channel podcast and blog are accessed by
more than 1.5 million
times each month and he's a family man a
faith-driven entrepreneur and leader and
also i'm honored to call him a friend
and so carrie thanks so much for coming
on the think
media podcast sean this is a thrill it's
just so good to hang out with you over
here thanks for having me
you as well and today we're going to be
talking about some concepts from your
book at your best now look at that yours
is more earmarked than mine is that's
it's mine's earmarked up i mean if
you're on the video version of the
podcast you could see that we have been
devouring i've been devouring this book
in fact think media our team has themed
our year at our best and so i'm excited
to dive into this conversation
but uh ultimately let's just get
straight into it and we'll get to your
story in a little bit but this idea of
burnout i mean there's been a lot of
articles actually surprisingly about
youtubers tick talkers are burning out
social media influencers are burning out
and there was a whole
string of articles about youtubers are
burning out these are people making a
ton of money but they're in a cycle of
all this high pressure all this you know
pressures of life pressures of fame
pressures of maybe being a small town
kid and all of a sudden you have
notoriety and how do you handle that but
ultimately from your studies and your
experience talking with leaders speaking
publicly coaching organizations how
prevalent is burnout for creators
leaders and ultimately knowledge workers
which is what the listeners of the think
media podcast are
yeah very prevalent actually and you
know i wish i had this phrase when i
wrote the book which just came out of
course but you'll learn this over time
but um the phrase that i heard recently
i think it goes back to albert tate is
people are overexposed and
underdeveloped and i'm like that
that is the money right there like we're
overexposed we're everywhere so all of a
sudden you know you're 18 years old you
have 5 million followers
or whatever i'm really glad that being
well known in the space that i'm known
in didn't happen to me when i was 32
because i think i would have collapsed
and i burned out at 40. we'll talk about
that later but here's the powerful thing
um i think about if you look at the
stats gallup etc 70
of people in the knowledge space would
say that they're burned out or they feel
burned out there was a poll done
the middle of 2021 by deloitte that said
something like 83 percent of knowledge
workers come home exhausted with nothing
left in the tank every day
and this is a problem before the
pandemic it's even worse now
so uh there's also like full-on burnout
where you don't function anymore i had
that where you're basically clinically
depressed but there's another form sean
that i call low-grade burnout and that i
define it as this the joy of life is
gone but the functions of life continue
so you're going to work you're showing
up but like you used to love youtube now
you're just like oh another day another
video another day another tick tock
another day another whatever and your
your heart is dead
wow and uh man i think listening to this
there's probably some of us right now
that are like i might be in low grade
burnout but you ultimately you you just
mentioned it you yourself experienced
high grade burnout right tell a little
bit about your story and what was
happening at the time and what led to
that anything worth doing is worth
overdoing so i really burned out um so
what happened to me i started i went to
law school then i went to seminary i
started working at a church when i was
30 and it went through a massive growth
curve at least in our country canada so
we became one of the largest churches in
our nomination in the country and the
fastest growing church in our
denomination and that kind of growth as
anybody knows is intoxicating in
whatever field you're in and it caused
me to ignore a lot of fundamentals uh
like how my heart was doing how my
marriage was doing
and you know my wife and i got into uh
some marriage turbulence in that season
but i thought as long as i was winning
at work everything was fine
and then um people kept telling me in my
late 30s like carrie you're gonna burn
out you're gonna burn out
and i didn't believe them because i
thought burning out was for weak people
but i i did one day and i did not
declare a finish line i didn't moderate
my workflow and my body quit and i went
into what would be probably called the
clinical depression for about four
months
where all the joy all the passion was
gone and i took a month off or three
weeks off and i thought okay this will
make it better it made it worse sean
made it worse so that was my burnout and
it was brutal
wow and uh thank you for sharing that
and i'm you know i'm excited because the
goal right is to figure out what are our
steps to get out of that whether it's
low grade or whether it's high grade
and ultimately beat stress and the
stress that a lot of us feel and i
actually kind of wanted to read a part
of your book before we get to the good
part of
of climbing out of all of this the price
of stress and this impacted me so much
because i think that for some of us and
if we're type a and driven we sometimes
ignore these things and so i started
reading this
on page eight of at your best and it
said the price of stress and these are
this is data this is showing what it can
lead to
stress can lead to heart attacks chronic
pain
shortness of breath full-on panic
attacks it's been linked to heartburn
acid reflux bloating nausea indigestion
and a loss of sexual
desire
memory function slowing your reaction
time
uh create creating behavioral and mood
disorders and then it even gets worse
you know when you really dig down
there's you know physical mental health
issues chronic fatigue obesity
depression man stress is really killing
us and there's a real cost to stress i
know for me
you kind of grow up and you just want to
be strong no matter what you know you
just want to press through no matter
what and so
in your book you talk about the stress
spiral and and i think it's that it's
when it just
we're in that loop and and i go into
that a little bit break that down you
know before we figure out how to get to
the thrive cycle and climb out of things
how can we well what's really happening
with the stress spiral and how do we get
in it so the stress spiral is if you can
imagine like a tornado-like thing and
it's just that you're cycling down and
if the book i really tried to deal with
because i you know on the other side of
burnout sean i tried to think about
how did i get here like what caused this
and how do i make sure i never go back
like as far as as humanly possible how
do i make sure i never go back so i
started to think about what are the
primary assets you deal with in
leadership and this is true for well any
human but especially knowledge workers
it's three things it's time
energy and priorities
time we all get 24 hours in a day energy
your energy level waxes and wanes over
the course of the day and priorities are
the things that you're supposed to get
done i got to ship that video i got to
write this i got to do whatever
and when you're in the stress spiral
your time is unfocused your energy goes
unleveraged and your priorities get
hijacked by everybody else and what that
leads in that downward spiral is to you
feeling overwhelmed over committed and
overworked so how do you know whether
you're in the stress spiral here are the
questions do you feel overwhelmed a lot
of people would say yes like 80 90
do you feel over committed yes i said
yes way too often
and do you feel overworked yeah and
guess what i work for myself but i feel
completely overworked so that's the
stress spiral
and so i th man i'm sure a lot of us can
relate to that and if the problem is
like
it's compounding because a lot of times
if we're if we're if we're feeling
overwhelmed we're being even less
productive if we're feeling overworked
it it or the to-do list stacks up even
more i know i can know the feeling of
paralysis where sometimes when you see
your to-do list and you're like
i'm actually going to do nothing instead
of even trying to tackle this because
where would i ever start and for the
knowledge workers and i think us as
youtube creators too there's a million
things to do and this of course is true
for you as a writer and so we can see
all the different things we've got the
emotional oppressors and we may be
dealing with um limited energy for any
number of reasons family work and all
kinds of different things so carrie
let's let's talk about really the
promise of this podcast
what do we start doing to climb up out
of this and what i love about this book
is actually when i got to the end of it
one of my favorite parts was
the acknowledgements and seeing how long
the story was this you know i think was
mark batterson that said man this needs
to be a book but that was
seven years ago or something yeah you
were buying the idea amongst thousands
of leaders in a course area you got to
test these theories and these practices
and actually prove them out so much
personal development leadership books in
in the world are sometimes just kind of
theories they may be worked for they
marked works i had an idea then i wrote
a book and here it is yeah exactly i had
an idea tried it once and it worked for
a while but like these are some really
proven practices and you also have the
credibility from
being in a clinical depression level of
burnout
and working your way up out of that so
maybe
lead us in a little bit of the story of
what happened next what you learned and
how that led to the discovery of the
thrive cycle and obviously we can't get
into all the details of it but what are
some of the pieces of the thrive cycle
that we could start overcoming overwhelm
over work and and starting to thrive
again yeah there's hope so it started
because as i hinted i was determined
to never put myself in that position
again it's so painful and some some of
the people watching some of the people
listening they burned out like and if
you've been there you know how miserable
it is and you wouldn't wish it on your
worst enemy so i'm like i don't ever
want to do this again to myself to other
people to the people i lead the people i
serve so i over a period of three to
five years i try to get back to normal
so i got like six months after the
lights went out and i burned out i
started to feel flickers of hope again
and i had a lot of muscle memory i've
been in leadership for a decade so i
didn't take a sabbatical i just went
back to work
and
eventually the joy started to come back
but i felt like i was like at 70 percent
60 percent 80 percent and eventually by
year four or five i was at 90 capacity
but all the while i'm reading books i'm
listening to podcasts i'm hiring coaches
i'm hiring consultants i'm i'm going to
counseling and i'm trying to create a
system a world view
where this wouldn't happen again
and i got to some success i would say by
year four or five i'm like okay i'm at a
new normal i'm at a hundred percent and
let's see if this thing holds well that
was 16 years ago that i started this and
so i just thought hey
like i found a system that works for me
and then within like five years of my
burnout the number one question i
started to get sean
was people coming up to me when they had
me one-on-one and going hey i know you
don't talk about this but how do you get
it all done like you've you've you're
working full-time at a church i was a
pastor at the time your family's in good
shape we we repaired it um
you are leading at a national level
you're speaking around the world you're
writing books you've got a podcast like
how do you get it all done and i'm like
well you know blah blah blah i didn't
have a good answer and then i thought
i'm gonna write it down and the first
time i wrote it down mark batterson
invited me to speak to his staff so i
went down and i put the principles down
in their first form and he pulled me
aside i wasn't even at my seat and he
goes this needs to be a book
well i didn't write the book but i did a
course we ran 3 000 leaders through the
course and gathered data from them and
then i taught it to thousands of leaders
around the world and now we're 20 almost
30 000 copies
into the book and so we now have data
points and stories anecdotes from tens
of thousands of leaders and the good
news is this stuff appears to work for
everyone and they see almost instant
results so if the stress spiral is
overwhelmed over committed overwork
and the problem is unfocused time
unleveraged energy and hijack priorities
the thrive cycle is not a tornado it is
a repeatable pattern and it starts by
focusing your time
leveraging your energy
realizing your priorities by doing what
you're best at when you're at your best
and the code underneath the thrive cycle
and this is where it started for me
is i knew i had to learn how to live in
a day and live in a way today that would
help me thrive tomorrow because for a
decade i lived in a way that would help
me
you know get exhausted for tomorrow um
barely survive into tomorrow and i was
living at an unsustainable pace
and so i started to use that mantra and
shared it with other leaders i'm i'm
going to live in a way today
that will help me thrive tomorrow and
when you leverage your time energy and
priorities in that way things start to
change and we can unpack that at
whatever level you want sean
yeah and i love leverage is one of my
favorite
words you know i think for any
entrepreneur and leader they want to
understand the power of leverage
uh investors understand the power of
leverage
in real estate you invest in a property
and if it's cash flowing it's working
for you when you're not working and so
creating leverage in your time and your
priorities is so powerful and and i have
a couple yeah we'll go through a couple
areas and i'll fire them off to you and
i want to actually kind of frame some
context on this of course these these
are i'm the leader of a team on its way
to about 25 team members now
um some are listening they're full-time
youtube creators or entrepreneurs
leveraging the power of youtube some are
in that side hustle season where they're
trying to juggle youtube and a job or
whatever else some are just starting
but i think one of probably the biggest
questions for our community
is
you know as a side hustle person
because you teach about the red zone the
yellows on the green zone and and we
want to create the best youtube content
possible and try to break through the
noise for online influence
we're we're going up against think media
like we're going up against a team of 25
people
and 2 million subscribers in that
momentum but i am i am david going up
against goliath and not only that i've
got kids i've got work
and i'm trying to do youtube on the side
i'm trying to create content on the side
i'm trying to write my book on the side
so my green zones go into a lot of other
places potentially
like carrie what are some principles
that can work for me
to actually also still i can't suck at
my job uh and i actually need to show up
in all these other areas of life but but
i really feel like the person we could
serve the best is the side hustle person
or the person that's juggling multiple
things and trying to get into that
thrive cycle and one of the first things
that stood out in your book that i'd
love for you to unpack is a lot of us a
lot of people in a lot of books talk
about time management but you talk about
energy management what do you mean by
that
yeah so i divide um every day into three
zones and i color code them just because
it's easy to think about
green yellow and red
so we all get 24 equal hours in the day
but those hours are not created equal so
most of us know instinctively maybe you
have some night owl creatives morning
people
listening i'm a morning person not by
nature but by design that design
happened when i got married and became a
dad many years ago so it's like all
right all of a sudden mornings are my
prime zone and if you think about it we
all know instinctively
that you have times of the day where
your energy is high you're generally in
a good mood for creativity if you're you
know scripting out a video or thinking
okay how we're gonna shoot this thing
your brain's working like it's creative
you've got stuff going if you're writing
a script you're like you're in flow and
that generally happens around the same
time every day
that's your green zone now the shocker
is for those of us who are driven and
entrepreneurs
that's only about
three to five hours a day and i know we
want to think we're robots no i got 12
hours
research again i did a lot of research
into this book too no all the experts
say you have three to five peak hours of
energy a day and your body will tell you
that because you you if you try to write
for 12 hours if you're writing a book
good luck because your 4 pm is not
nearly as good as your 7 a.m so you got
to think green is your prime time
red is that time where you're exhausted
it's like red bull you got three brain
cells left you can barely stay awake for
the meeting you need a nap or a run or
whatever and for me that's four to six
every day and then yellow zone is
everything in between which is actually
great time you can do meetings in it i
do a lot of my po i'm known for
podcasting i do a lot of my podcast
interviews during my yellow zone do my
prep in my green zone interviews in my
yellow zone divide your day into those
three zones green yellow red and then
here's the secret this is the archimedes
lever
do what you're best at when you're at
your best take those things like it's
script writing or it's shooting that
video or it's you know team development
whatever that is do it in your green
zone because what happens is if you
don't do it in your green zone if you
don't do it when you're at your best
that's what you carry home and that's a
mistake i was making in my 20s and 30s
is i'd kind of goof off not aware i had
a green zone i'd go do breakfast
meetings i'll do other meetings and then
i got a sermon to write or i got a court
case to prepare for or i've got a book
chapter to turn in and then what do you
do you open up your laptop at six
o'clock and say sorry family i'm done
with you i gotta work tonight and you're
not even producing your best work so
flip it do your best work in your green
zone and take it from there
so powerful and one of the biggest
killers of i think
professionally even in turn inside of
our organizations but also potentially
in the external requests from outside of
our organizations is over commitment
if every single time we say yes to
somebody
we are ultimately saying no to one of
our priorities potentially even every
yes is a no and every no is a yes
and i know that i discovered recently
that i'm actually opportunity led
and i also discovered that i am a people
pleaser and i want to make people happy
or i hate saying no
um and and i probably lean more to the
opportunity-led side of i just fear of
missing out on uh you know a request to
do something absolutely a request to do
this absolutely not necessarily thinking
it through i think the pandemic was a
great reset button because eventually
my travel was so full i was just saying
yes to every opportunity because i might
meet somebody and it might lead to
something and it could lead to this and
we got to keep fighting we got to keep
pushing
but one of the super powers
for
getting into the thrive cycle
getting out of the stress
spiral
and really being at our best
is learning how to say no and getting
over the fear of other people's opinions
can you unpack that a little bit with
any tips so full disclosure it's still
hard
i say no 90 of the time
and you know you eventually you must
have this sean like you've got a big
social media footprint
and i mean youtube sends you plaques
right so i mean at that point you're a
person of influence
and we i asked my team recently i said
how many times do we get pitched today
because we're 21 million downloads and
counting on my podcast
and they're like 10 to 15. i i don't
even hear most of those 10 to 15 a day
very few come to me
but then i get hit up with friends who
are like texting me and who have my
email and they're like hey can you hey
can you because when you become an
influencer so to speak right everybody
wants you to lend your influence to them
so there's there's two problems number
one if you're in the position you're in
or i'm in you get hit up all the time if
you're starting out for the side hustle
people you think everything you should
do absolutely everything you can because
you got to get your name out there
i would say
you should default to yes if you're just
starting out as long as it doesn't
compromise your health or compromise
your time or whatever so i mean if
you're sitting there going i got nothing
to do and someone says hey will you come
on this you know instagram live with me
or will you do this joint venture with
me or will you speak at this event you
should probably say yes but before you
know it your calendar is going to fill
up and then you need to develop a filter
so we have a filter that we use in my
company and in my life and it's
constantly being refined and it will get
narrower well the filter will get
stronger and stronger as time goes on
and as your platform grows but i did
start out by saying yes to everything
and then it became a problem because
there were too many things and you had
to say no
so you know i have a filter for is i'm a
leadership quote expert that's what i do
is it a leadership event if it's not a
leadership event it's almost always a no
and then we look at well who's going to
be in the room because i would rather
talk to 150 influencers than 1500
general leaders i think there's greater
impact there then there's part of am i
passionate about the event is this
really something i can speak to or are
people just asking me to talk into the
ether because like i've got some areas
of expertise and if it's not in my area
of expertise i'm probably not the best
person to do your event and then you've
got the opportunity cost right uh sean
you talked about opportunity you follow
opportunity but there's also an
opportunity cost
before the pandemic i was flying over
100 000 miles a year you know all of a
sudden the borders close planes stop
flying everything gets a big reset
because i'm canadian most of my work's
in america
the border was closed effectively for 18
months so we did a big reset we think
i'm probably going to fly half of that
in the future and the reason is
opportunity cost because when i'm on a
plane traveling to your event and you're
paying me even if you're paying me well
for doing the event i am not developing
my next online course i'm not leading my
team in other words i can make x dollars
by speaking at this event but i could
make perhaps more or make a bigger
impact or be a better leader by being
here and actually building into my team
so you got to think about all those
things and then you got to figure out
how to say no and because i'm canadian
you got to figure out how to do it
nicely and so we can talk about that how
do you say no nicely but those are some
thoughts about saying no
yeah i love that and i want to recommend
people um of course to definitely pick
up a copy of the book and we'll have a
link in the show notes and in the
youtube description um you know i really
recommend getting a physical copy and i
encouraged shayla and jordan on our team
to print out to blow up and print out
your scripts for saying no
they're not just powerful but they're
all so kind because that's our thing
it's like how do you how do you also
kindly tee up and communicate a no but
also you want to
steward the relationship you don't want
to close a door because it might just be
no for now right it might just be so
anyways there's some there's some
scripts in the book i highly recommend
you take advantage of those because no
will be a superpower but i actually want
to move into
uh another area and that's the idea of
killing distractions
um and the idea of also optimizing your
environment you know i'm learning from
your book and seeing in general with
great works out there like deep work and
and then just all the studies of how
much we're distracted you're talking
about we're we're on our phones or we
touch our phones 2 500 plus times a day
if we have a real problem it's over 5000
i think i have a real problem i have a
real problem
yeah
and of course we use our phones for work
but it's also easy to go to them for the
scroll but not only that we got
notifications on our smart watches we
got people just calling us out of the
blue we got text messages out of the
blue and one of the most shocking stats
that
is revealed in your book
is that once we're interrupted
it takes us as much as 25 minutes to get
refocused
now carrie this really troubled me
because it made me think that
if someone on my team
got interrupted
right
you know
six uh eight times a day or 16 times a
day which is likely
and it took a half hour to get focused
again well then all eight hours we're
never focused
because it's another half hour you want
me to make your problem worse multiply
that by 25 sean
thank you you want to see a whole bunch
of money go down the toilet that's how
to see it
and so distractions and and even more so
so whether that's inside of an
organization or whether that's of course
for individuals who are also saying okay
i want to build my side hustle and they
got very limited hours they got 5 10 15
hours a week to build up that side
hustle because they maybe want to quit
their nine to five you know go into
something else well if you give any time
at all to distractions then you are
actually you're kind of killing your
chance of being at your best and doing
really productive work and so touch on
that a little bit on the distractions
piece and then we can maybe talk about
some remedies or both at the same time i
read that stat it blew me away 25
minutes and let me nuance it a little
bit because cal newport makes the
helpful distinction between shallow work
and deep work so i don't do email for a
living but email would be like shallow
work for me it's like then an
interruption is not as big but when
you're writing a book when you're
creating a
master class when you're filming the
video that you know is going to make a
big difference what you're involved in
at that point is deep work because
you're creating something out of nothing
there was no book there were no ideas
you got to go deep
when that happens you're tapping away on
your keyboard you know your phone buzzes
the doorbell rings whatever it is
someone knocks on your door
and you kind of lose focus you're like
yeah what do you want or i gotta go
check this out or what do you mean you
got some news notification or whatever
and when you come back you're like now
where was i
that's what it's talking about and
sometimes you know this as a creative
you don't get those ideas back like they
don't come back to you you're like
they're just gone and you're like oh and
you're in the shower the next morning
trying to think about it you're on a
walk trying to think about it you don't
get those ideas back or if you do
you're like okay i think i'm over here
that's why i mean no brainer all
notifications off your phone's on do not
disturb and so many people i've had mine
on do not disturb for years thank
goodness ios 15 introduced focus mode so
if you're like well i don't want to cut
out my assistant i don't want to cut out
my kids great program them into ring
through and train them not to call you
during your green zone like do not like
this is a nuclear emergency if you're
reaching me during my green zone because
then you'll get deep work done and near
al and cal newport and other
you know thought leaders like that would
say
focus is the superpower in this age of
distraction and i agree your ability to
do deep deep work and to think beyond
where most people think
that's where you're going to get your
progress so notifications off the other
thing about environment like you're in
the basement of my house that's what
you're watching right now
and so i built this out maybe five or
six years ago and i thought very i'm
very impacted by environment so i'm like
okay if this is where i'm working i've
got a barn door it you know shuts out
the stairs and everything beyond that i
can put my headphones in
and just like i hear nothing and then in
the summer i have like four offices
because i've got a backyard i can sit by
the fire pit i can sit in the pavilion i
can sit on the back deck i can sit on
the front porch in the morning and i
just sit there with my laptop and i love
getting stuff done we live in the
country so it's a quiet environment but
you probably have that ideal environment
and if you're in a cubicle right a lot
of you probably aren't
you have your noise cancelling
headphones and get the big ones because
noise cancelling headphones are also
people-cancelling headphones because it
takes an awful lot to interrupt somebody
when they've got the big cans on and
they're you know kind of look like
they're focused so that's what you can
do and i've had to write chapters of
books on airplanes and airports at
hotels in lobbies you know at the beach
etc you can do that but ideally you want
an optimal environment and thank
goodness this is 2022 because a lot of
people didn't have home offices prior to
the pandemic and then everybody upgraded
so hopefully you've got some little
cubicle carved out somewhere where you
can get some work done
yeah that's one of my favorite tips and
i think such an opportunity for our
community um
focus is a super power in this age of
distraction
friends we got to get out of burnout and
we want to get into the thrive cycle and
you know definitely tapping into some
tips in the book but i love the content
about optimal environment and it reminds
me kerry of when i was working actually
at a church with some of the think media
team members i was the director of
communications
um at one point sonia was my assistant
my wife
i had an office and it kind of had a
mini desk where she would sit it had my
desk
and then down the hall was kind of the
we had a tv show and there would be the
editors and we had mario and kyle and
then eventually omar
and they would be working at other
places and one of the things sonya
observed because i have a big heart and
kind of an open door
uh mentality was she would notice i'd be
trying to work away write a script or
something and then boom mario would show
up and be like hey can you come look at
this and then i'd be like actually i
can't but even him showing up and and
then somebody kyle would show up and be
like hey can you and then throughout the
day and sonia she's kind of got this
viking wired personality she was just
like
why are you just bursting in the door
what's going on and i'm kind of unaware
and in that season i actually learned
that if you're actually in manage
coaching leadership mode you just want
to be fully in that mode go look at the
things you know be there to coach be
there to mentor but if you need to
actually write some scripts or build
some stuff out i was helping my pastor
at the time who i was working for write
books and so on and so forth and i
learned this lesson that those
interrupted so i would start to close my
door i'd sometimes put up a sign and i
remember too even other people in the
the office were like what's what's he
was he got that sign up who's he think
he is uh he thinks he's focused he
thinks he's gonna get some things done
that's who he thinks he is and uh and i
really learned that and i started to
learn about my myself about the
importance of optimal environments and i
love to like even when the door is open
at my home office even if the house is
quiet i feel the door open even if i
don't see it i can actually feel that
the door is open kind of feeling the
nose around the noise around me you
mentioned even your book that maybe
it's like a buzzing sound could even
sort of take you out of the zone it's
funny my wife loves having a noise
machine on or a fan on
or or even she'll leave the washing
washer and dryer room door open
and i'll be like hey can you close she
actually kind of likes that here's the
key neither of us are right or wrong you
got to be self-aware what is your
optimal
environment dude right outside there is
the door to what we call our furnace
room with the furnace and ac are and
like if that door is a jar and people
will leave it a jar i'm like i gotta get
up i gotta close it i can't deal with
you gotta close it i got it yeah and
yeah some people aren't necessarily
thinking about that but i wanna
encourage the think media podcast
community
man optimize your environment and and
carry out i mean i think this is a good
use of money i know resources can be
scarce depending on where we are but you
invested in that office wouldn't it you
got pillows if you're on the video
podcast you got chairs got lighting it's
a whole mood but man when you're a
knowledge worker your environment
matters you know i think media i am
obsessed with battle stations i'm like
listen you need two monitors you need a
standing desk you need uh you need to be
able to close the door you need a good
mic you need good lighting you need to
be able to focus you need like you got
to get your battle station built that we
actually sent out gear to our team
because it just matters so much
and uh and speak a little bit about that
though just landing the plane as far as
optimal environment yeah it's really
interesting design has become a much
bigger thing in the last 15 years and
good design teaches you what to do so
last summer
we were thinking about building a house
and then the real estate market went
crazy and we're like i'm not playing
that game so we renovated my backyard
and uh one day i'll give you a video
tour or an in-person tour of it but we
built like a new fire pit that's sort of
out in the middle of the backyard then
we put up a pavilion that seats 10. it's
nice and big there's a hot tub and then
there's a dining area and then there's
like a lounge area on the back porch and
it's really interesting because as we've
hosted people
over the last six months since that
space has been open and we designed it
for the winter too there's heaters and
all that stuff
you don't have to tell anybody what to
do my wife and i when we were designing
it were like oh i hope this is going to
work and we can do 30 people here people
just walk into the backyard they
instinctively know where to go and what
to do and they just make themselves
comfortable you're not like well two of
you sit over there and two of you that's
what space does when i come into this
space i got a tv in the back and i put
that in a few years ago because i
thought oh it can be a second family
room this is my workspace man this is
what i do this is i never use this for
recreation and um
and it tells me like it's my cue it's my
signal that when i come in here i have
my devotions in the morning i'm a
christian um but then this is work mode
and in the backyard it is sort of hybrid
work and pleasure but when i'm back
there i'm like i'm in focus mode i'm
enjoying myself i'm the privilege of
being back here
write something create something and
whatever that is for you and everybody's
a little bit different
find some space design some space paint
a room a color you really like and then
just
make that your space
you will find that it then triggers you
to get into productivity and
well-designed space because otherwise
you're awkward you're like a square peg
in a round hole that buzzing fluorescent
light that you know the room smells bad
or you can always hear the microwave
beep from the and now remote work is a
thing so there are people who can work
in coffee shops i cannot i am like
watching everybody coming and going what
are they ordering i'm 280 d so i need
silence i need this
well that was part one of our series
here with carrie newhoff i'm excited to
jump into next week's episode but i want
to ask you this question are you at your
best i'll make sure to link the book
down below in the description box or in
the youtube description and i highly
recommend picking up this book and
listening to it on audible getting the
kindle version that's digital or getting
the physical copy and actually taking
some time this month to read this book
carrie is a wealth of knowledge when it
comes to understanding when you are in
your thrive cycle when you're in your
green zone and when you're in your red
zone and he gives you a ton of exercises
of how to really figure out when you
work best so i want to encourage you to
grab that book wherever books are sold
and i'll link it down below in the
description box as well now every single
week we love to read one of the reviews
from the podcast and thank you so much
to everyone who's taken the time to rate
and review the podcast over on apple
podcast today comes from ellie lee
designs saying fantastic just upped my
daily commute game that makes me so
excited that you listen to us on your
commute love the new youtube features
you can't ignore podcasts this was
extremely helpful and so easy to take in
i thought listening on youtube was great
but this just upped my daily commute
game thank you ellie thank you so much
for sharing that with us thanks for
letting me know when you love to listen
to the podcast which is on your commute
which makes me excited to know that
we're a part of your daily life thank
you for all those who have raided and
reviewed and i want to encourage you to
take a moment after you're done
listening to this one and let us know
what you think about the podcast next
week we're jumping into part two with
carrie newhoff we're gonna be talking
all about the secrets of being a highly
productive content creator and the
difference between doing deep work and
shallow work oh no i can't wait for next
week's episode so join us here on the
podcast thank you so much for listening
and we'll catch you next week bye
[Music]
you